Okay. Guten Tag. Mein Name ist Gümüş. Ich bin hier des Ust-Standge-Erste-In-Für-Sie. Ich werde mich um Ihre Beschwerden kümmern.
Aber vorher möchte ich wieder personische Daten erfassen. Bitte geben Sie mir Bescheid, wenn Sie etwa nicht verstehen.
Ja klar.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, ja, natürlich. Ja klar.
Wie heißen Sie da?
Ich heiße Willi Jäger.
Willi Jäger.
Könnten Sie bitte in der Fortnachnahme langsam büsterieren?
Ja, Willi ganz einfach.
W-I-W-L-I
I? Okay.
Und dann Jäger. J-A-Umblaut-G-E-R.
Jäger.
I-R-Sch.
Ich bin dein Mann, ne?
Herr Jäger.
Nee, nicht Jäger.
Jäger.
G-E-R am Ende.
Okay.
Ja, klar.
Ja, Herr Jäger.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 59.
59.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 16. Mai 66.
Okay.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,74.
Da heif ich jetzt noch 75 Kilo.
75?
Okay.
Und Sie so uns Herr Jäger.
Ja, wissen Sie, mit meinem Hals und mit meinem Schlucken sind das immer schlimmer.
Ich habe immer solche Schmerzen, wenn ich schlucke.
Das sind keine normalen Halsschmerzen.
Das drückt auch hier so richtig so hier oben in der Brust.
Und früher war das so, dass ich gedacht habe,
ja, hast du nicht gut gekaut, hast du wieder mal zu schnell gegessen und so.
Und ja, man kennt, dass wenn man so trockenes Brot ist oder so,
dass man sagt, ach jetzt, ich hängt mir das irgendwie fest.
Aber inzwischen ist es eigentlich so bei allem, was ich esse.
Und jetzt ist es auch, wenn ich, wenn ich etwas Kühles trinke,
dass mir das weh tut, so hier in dem Halsbereich und vor allen Dingen hier so oberhalb der Brust.
Da tut es ganz doll weh.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerde?
Ja, das hat so vor drei Wochen angefangen.
Drei Wochen.
Manchmal fühlt sich das an, als ob ich so ein Kloß im Hals habe.
Ja, also ganz komisches Gefühl.
Komisches Gefühl.
Sind die Beschwerden dauerhafter oder gehen sie auch wieder weg?
Ja, also inzwischen ist es schon so, dass ich dieses enge Gefühl habe,
eigentlich fast ständig.
Und ja, insbesondere ist es natürlich extrem beim Essen und Trinken.
Essen und Trinken.
Wie haben sich die Beschwerden mit der Zeit verändert haben,
die Beschwerden so genommen oder nachgelassen?
Ja, ja, das ist, also am Anfang habe ich gedacht, naja, hast du falsch geschluckt und so.
Aber jetzt wird es immer schlimmer, deswegen bin ich auch gekommen.
Ja, haben Sie, können Sie genau beschreiben,
sind Sie diese Haarschmerzen, die Sie haben,
sind Sie diese Haarschmerzen drückend brennend?
Also überwiegend würde ich sagen drückend.
Also so dieses Gefühl, dass da so ein Kloß ist, naja.
Aber es sticht und brennt auch ein bisschen, ja.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Skalafone, wobei nur keine Schmerzen,
und sehr starken Schmerzen beruhten?
Ach, das kann ich schwer sagen.
Schlimmer geht immer.
Also vielleicht so 4 oder 5 oder so in der Mitte.
Haben Sie Brustchmerzen oder Haarsrazen, Haarsklopfen bemerkt?
Nee, nee, nee, Haarsklopfen habe ich nicht.
Das sitzt irgendwie so höher, dieses Grockgefühl.
Sind die Strangeschmerzen in anderer Körperregion aus?
Nee, nee, nee.
Okay. Gibt es bei Ihnen Atemnot?
Nein, nein, nein, nein, das habe ich nicht.
Luft kann ich ohne Weiteres bekommen.
Okay.
Haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden?
Ja, also was mir aufgefallen ist, das ist mir in letzter Zeit irgendwie
insgesamt nicht so gut geht.
Weil das Schlucken so unangenehm ist, fällt mir das so ganz besonders auf.
Also einmal, dass ich so ein bisschen so aufstoßen muss,
und dann immer das Gefühl, oh, kommt da jetzt was mit.
Und dann habe ich auch, das ist ganz blöd, das ist so dieses Gefühl wie beim Zahnarzt,
wenn man den Mund aufmacht und die kommen damit ihr sauber,
hat man ja das Gefühl, man läuft ganz viel Spuckel.
Und so habe ich das jetzt auf, dass ich immer das Gefühl habe,
oh, ich will doch nicht schlucken, aber da kommt so viel Speichel
und immer noch mehr und immer noch mehr,
und dabei tut mir doch das Schlucken so weh.
Ja, das ist ganz blöd.
Okay. Habt ihr sie geschwollene im Haarsbereich?
Ich weiß nicht, ob da was geschwollene ist,
das ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Also, ich trage natürlich auch keine engen Hemden oder so was.
Haben sie Sotbrennen oder Sauris im Geschmack im Mund?
Ganz seltenmal, ja.
Habt ihr sie heißigkeit?
Ne, heißer bin ich eigentlich nicht, ne?
Ja, okay. Habt ihr sie fieber nach Schweiß oder Stuhlfrost bemerkt?
Ne, also, aber ich fühle mich nicht fieberig, das würde ich jetzt nicht sagen.
Und schlafen, naja, kann ich eigentlich immer so ganz gut.
Schlafstörung, haben Sie?
Nein, ich habe keine Schlafstörung.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Ja, der ist zurzeit wirklich mau, also es schmeckt mir überhaupt nicht.
Und ich habe auch, das ist mir jetzt aufgefallen die Tage,
ich habe auch 3 kg abgenommen in letzter Zeit.
3 kg abgenommen?
Ich würde sagen in einem Monat.
Ein Monat. Aber es schmeckt ja auch einfach nicht.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Ist Ihnen übel, müssen Sie erbrechen?
Ne, Gott sei Dank, nicht ne.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Normalerweise nicht, ne?
Haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhlgang?
Ja, zurzeit bin ich manchmal so ein bisschen verstopft, das kenne ich eigentlich gar nicht.
Seit wann haben Sie Verstopfen?
Ach, vielleicht so im letzten Vierteljahr oder so,
dass mir das aufgefallen ist.
Wie bitte, letzten?
Im letzten 3 Monaten, im letzten Vierteljahr.
Letzten 3 Monaten?
Ja, wie sagt Ihr Stuhl aus?
Normalerweise sieht er so wie immer aus, aber wo Sie fragen, fällt mir das ein.
Dass das in den letzten Tagen 2-mal mehr aufgefallen ist,
dass das so ganz dunkler Stuhl war, das sah ganz anders aus als sonst.
Dunkler Stuhl.
Haben Sie Blut dabei?
Blut habe ich nicht darauf geachtet, aber habe ich nicht gesehen, ne.
Ich weiß, ich war da nix.
Okay, verstehe. Leiden Sie an vor Erkrankungen?
Ja, also ich habe seit 4 Jahren schon so ein Altersdiabetes.
Sonst noch?
Sonst habe ich eigentlich keine Probleme.
Keine Probleme.
Okay. Sie haben aktuelle Beschwerden.
Hatten Sie früher schon einmal ernehmliche Beschwerden?
Nein, also das habe ich noch nie so erlebt.
Das wäre ich vielleicht auch nicht gekommen, wenn ich das schon mal gehabt hätte,
aber das kann mir jetzt irgendwie merkwürdig vor.
Okay. Sind Sie deswegen schon bei einem anderen ausgewiesen?
Nein, nein, nein, da bin ich gar nicht beim Haus ausgewiesen.
Der kümmert sich immer nur um die Diabetes-Tabletten.
Welche Tablette wissen Sie?
Ja, die heißen Ikandra.
Wie bitte?
Ikandra heißen die, da nehme ich morgens und abends eine.
Ikandra?
Okay. Abends und morgens.
Ja genau, nehme ich hier eine, ja.
Wissen Sie, welcher Dosierung?
Nein, das kann ich Ihnen nicht sagen.
Da stehen irgendwie Zahlen drauf, aber ich weiß das nicht.
Okay. Nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder gelegentliche Medikamente aus, Ikandra?
Nieses, nimm ich nichts ein.
Okay. Wurden Sie schon mal operiert?
Ja, so eine Kleinigkeit.
Da hatte ich, so am linken Ellenbogen, so eine Steinbeutel-Enzynion.
Und das ist dann operiert worden, es war aber nur eine Kleinigkeit.
Wann war das?
Das ist jetzt zwölf Jahre her.
Was ist zwölf Jahre?
Vor zwölf Jahren war das, ja.
Okay. Sonst noch an der Operation?
Ja, als Kind habe ich mal die Wendeln rausbekommen, ja.
Okay. Sind die Operationen Komplikationen ausverlaufen?
Ja, das war ja nur eine Kleinigkeit jeweils, ja.
Ausverlaufen.
Sind Beinen aller Gen oder Umverträglichkeiten bekannt?
Ja, ich muss tatsächlich ein bisschen aufpassen.
Was ich nicht nehmen darf, ist die Kluffinak.
Und dann habe ich so eine Allergie auf Gräser.
Also auf Gräserpollen insbesondere.
Und jetzt im Sommer, wenn die Gräser blühen, das ist für mich so eine Zeit, da geht es mir nicht so gut.
Okay. Die Kluffinak-Allergie haben Sie, wie reagieren Sie darauf?
Da kriege ich einen Hautausschlag.
Ausschlag.
Okay. Gräser-Allergie, hohe Schnuffen, oder?
Ja, also so eine tränende Augen und Schnuffenase.
Okay. Rauchen Sie?
Ja, aber ich rauche schon ziemlich lange, ja.
Wie viele Zigarette rauchen Sie am Tag?
Ein Päckchen geht schon drauf, ja. Ein Päckchen am Tag rauche ich schon, ja.
Wie lange rauchen Sie?
Seit ich 18 bin, also ja, das gehört immer dazu, ja.
Seit dem 18. Jahr?
Seit dem 18. Jahr, mhm.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, also ich trinke abends nach Feierabend so oder so zum Einschlafen trinke ich zwei Bier.
Und manchmal trinke ich auch einen Schnaps, ja, wenn es etwas zu feiern gibt
oder am Wochenende oder nach einem guten Essen, ja, aber zur Zeit schmeckt mir der Schnaps,
aber wirklich nicht so gut, ja, das muss ich schon sagen.
Zwei Flöße?
Zwei Flaschen Schnaps und Gottes Wille, nein, zwei, drei Gläser Schnaps.
Okay.
Zwei Flaschen Gläser oder Flöße?
Schnaps, zwei Gläser Schnaps und zwei Flaschen Bier täglich, ja.
Zwei Flasche Bier oder zwei Gläser Schnaps.
Okay.
Oder Beides.
Aber manchmal Feierabend.
Ja, genau.
Okay.
Bitte nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht persönlich, das ist reine Routinefrage.
Nehmen Sie Drogensosie?
Nein, nein, nein.
Okay.
Was ist Ihr von Beruf?
Ich arbeite in einer großen Firma an der Forte und in einer Telefonzentrale.
Telefon, ich kann Sie wiederholen bitte.
Ich arbeite in einer Telefonzentrale und als Partner in einer großen Firma.
Okay.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verwidert.
Okay.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, aber die sind zum Glück aus dem Grünsten raus, ja, ja, aber die,
die sind auch hier bei mir angebunden und ja, die leben noch bei mir in der
Wohnung, aber die sind so dabei sich selbstständig zu machen.
Herr Schuldugun, wie viele Kinder haben Sie?
Zwei.
Zwei Kinder.
Mhm.
Sind Sie gesund?
Sie sind gesund, ja.
Danke.
Ich habe für mich, Herr Schuldugun, ich habe eine Frage zum
gesundheitsverzüglichen, ihre Eltern oder Geschwester.
Meine Schwester kann ich gar nicht bieten, die habe ich gar nicht.
Okay.
Leiden ihre Eltern krank und...
Also mein Vater, der hat Magen geschwürt, das weiß ich,
und meine Mutter ist früh gestorben, die hatte, die hatte Darmkrebs.
Mein Vater, der hat jetzt ein bisschen zu tun mit Magen geschwürt.
Okay.
Ich habe für mich alle Fragen gestaltet.
Haben Sie eine Frage an mich oder möchten Sie noch etwas hüße fügeln?
Ja, ich habe natürlich die Frage, ob ich meine Mutter,
meine Mutter, meine Mutter, meine Mutter, meine Mutter, meine Mutter
und meine Mutter...
Also ich meine, ich habe eine Frage an mich oder möchten Sie noch
etwas hüße fügeln?
Ja, ich habe natürlich die Frage, wie kann das kommen,
dass ich mich so schlapp fühle und, ja, auch, dass ich so abgenommen
habe und das mich gar nicht schmeckt und so.
Und natürlich auch, diesehouseschmerzen.
Ja, ich vermute, dass sie Speiseröhre Probleme haben, aber das ist nun mein Verdachtdiagnose.
Um mein Verdachtdiagnose so bestätigen werde ich so erst die Körperlöhung untersuchen, Vitalparameter messen
und bei ihnen Ultraschall durchführen, Hassbereit und Abdomen Ultraschall durchführen, ein EKG schreiben lassen, Röntgenaufnahme machen lassen, nachher lernen,
Röntgenaufnahme, wovon machen Sie Röntgenaufnahme?
Ja, Röntgenaufnahme, Hassbereit und Bauch, besonders.
Von Hals und Bauch, ok?
Als Brust und Bauch.
Ok.
Haben Sie eine Frage an mich?
Nein, das wird schon alles so seine Richtigkeit haben und dann können Sie sagen, was wir dagegen tun können, ja?
Wie bitte?
Und dann, wenn wir das alles untersucht haben, dann können Sie mir sagen, was dagegen geht.
Nach allerer Ergebnissen kann ich Ihnen Bescheid geben, was Sie genau haben und wie wir weiter vorgehen werden.
Das klingt gut, ja.
Was mag ich denn auf jemandem fragen?
Nix, keine Fragen offen?
Wir gucken.
Ich habe eine neue Patientin, darf ich bei den Berichten haben, sie ist Zeit für mich?
Ja, natürlich.
Ok, mein Patient, Willy Jaeger, Herr Jaeger, 59 Jahre alt, am 16. Mai, Mai 1900, 6.6 geboren.
Richtig?
Er ist 1,74 m groß und 75 kg schwer.
Er stammelt sich bei uns heute wegen, seit drei Wochen bestehende, progradiente,
halb schmerzen und kloske fühl beim Schluke und besonders es und trinken vor.
Er beschreibt die Schmerzen als durigend und brennend.
Schmerzintensität liegt bei 5 von 10, Alfa-Enerz-Kala.
Er hat eine Ausstrahlung, er klagte über Ausstoßen und Selten, so brennen.
Sie hat keine Fieber, keine Nachschweiß, seine Appetit ist nicht gut,
Sie hat 3 kg, er hat eine Monat abgenommen.
Er hat keine Übelkeit und erbrochen.
Er hat Verstopfung, die drei Monaten.
Er hat seit vier Jahren die Appetit mehltet,
er nimmt 2 Mal ein, wegen linken Albo-Entsündung eine Operation vor 12 Jahren wurde durcheführt
und er hat eine Erhöhung mit Erno-Konjuktivitis.
Er braucht eine Paketik täglich seit dem Assyntelabansia.
Er hat eine Erhöhung mit Erno-Konjuktivitis.
Er arbeitet im Telefonzentrale und ist verbitwit, hat zwei Kinder.
Bevor Sie sich auf die körperlichen Untersuchungen achten, achten Sie besonders?
Was erwarten Sie bei der Labo-Untersuchung?
Was erwarten Sie?
Was machen Sie an technischen Untersuchungen?
Was spricht gegen die Diagnose eines Ösefaguskarcinums?
Er hat typische Zemptome für Ösefaguskarcinums.
Er hat 3 kg Abgönung innerhalb eines Monats.
Er hat 2 Mal Melena.
Er spricht für das.